Spacetime is not a stage.
It is the cast.
Mass and energy press on it; the Einstein tensor measures how deeply they press.
The Moon.
Its Schwarzschild radius is only 0.11 millimeters — smaller than a grain of sand.
The curvature you see here is what an ant on the lunar surface would actually feel.
The Earth.
r-sub-s equals 8.95 millimeters.
The entire planet would have to collapse to that size to become a black hole.
We orbit the Sun, we feel gravity, yet the geometric distortion is only one part in ten to the nine.
The Sun.
Schwarzschild radius 2.95 kilometers; physical radius nearly 700 000 kilometers.
The well looks deep here only because we plot in r-s units.
In reality, spacetime around the Sun is still 99.9996 % flat.
But enough to bend starlight by 1.75 arc-seconds — the measurement that confirmed General Relativity in 1919.
R136a1 — the most massive single star known.
Roughly 200 solar masses, in the Tarantula Nebula.
Despite that, the gravitational distortion at its surface is still only 8 × 10⁻⁵.
Stars cannot break spacetime by mass alone — only by collapse.
A 10 M☉ black hole.
Now the radius equals r-s.
The full Flamm paraboloid is exposed.
Inside the horizon, time and radius swap roles.
This is what spacetime pressed past its breaking point looks like.
But it has only one mouth.
Whatever falls in cannot come out.
The Star-Gate.
Two Schwarzschild geometries glued at a throat — an Einstein-Rosen bridge.
Two mouths, one shortcut.
To hold the throat open against its urge to collapse, you need exotic matter — matter with negative energy density.
How much energy does that cost?
The Einstein equations give a classical estimate: c⁴ × b₀ divided by big-G.
For a two-meter gate, wide enough for a person to walk through, that is 2.4 × 10⁴⁴ joules.
To make that real: it equals about 10³¹ Hiroshima bombs.
A one with thirty-one zeros after it.
It equals every nuclear weapon currently on Earth, detonated at once, sixteen septillion times in a row.
It equals four hundred sextillion years of total world energy production.
Or, most directly: it equals one and a half Jupiters, annihilated into pure energy.
Ford and Roman's quantum inequalities allow exotic energy only on the order of ℏc divided by b₀.
For the same gate: less than a millionth of a billionth of a joule.
The classical requirement exceeds the quantum allowance by seventy orders of magnitude.
Until physics closes that gap, the Star-Gate stays science fiction.